I walked into the bunker and she was
just there I saw you die I was saved
I think it's important that we embrace
the miracles
she was dead now she's not that's time
travel for him
tell me
for you
I'm atheist is proving to me that I will
destroy myself and everyone close to me
this is getting good
hey youtubers is Charlie new arrow
footage let's break it down we got black
Simon we got Prometheus they tease more
kovar heavy flashbacks and they even
have some Donald Trump jokes that'll be
happening in the flashbacks that I'll
explain so there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway yeah you know
everything's back or you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a flash
arrow DC related comment on this video
winners are always announced at the end
of videos be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so that you don't miss
anything
I love the tip from wild dog this is
getting good so this is really like the
black siren trailer with Prometheus
there's also some rush of flashback
stuff that all address because the
producers were talking about Cove art
Dolph Lundgren's character how he's
gonna be huge in the back half of the
season so let's start with the black
sirens stuff first though so they're all
questioning like you know who are you
and then there's the reveal so you see a
couple different versions of Katie
Cassidy you see the first version that
was from the end of episode 9 where
she's just like I've been saved and then
they all seem like they believe that
it's time travel some flashpoint twist
but then later they cut all the footage
of everything exploding or using the
canary cry to blow up everything all
over the place you actually see her use
it a couple different times in the
episode the other like really big WTF
one is blowing up the Black Canary
statue so there's like an explosion
coming from this side of the screen but
then you see the sonic screen coming
from the other side so they're just
crazy [ __ ] happening wild dog is not
lying is is definitely getting good I
wasn't really happy when they killed the
character off but I understand how they
sort of needed to soft reboot that
version of Laurel just because they
drugged her through the mud so much so
there wasn't that many places left to
take her and she wasn't a metahuman so
they couldn't do real Black Canary so
there are a lot of different ways that
they could use her going forward it just
depends on which version they want to go
with in how they want to either redeem
or throw this character in the mud make
her a villain for the rest of the run
they've already been picked up for
season 6 so she'll definitely be back
for Season 6 and Katie Cassidy will be
back so you have to remember that
sometimes when she comes back she plays
Laurel in flashback she plays different
versions of the character so I'm totally
happy if they continue to do it that way
but they haven't really said how many
more episodes this season
she's gonna be in in what's gonna happen
next season because if she's not gonna
be a series regular I really just want
to see her come back and their user for
metahuman Black Canary stories even if
it's black siren just turned good so it
just depends on how this all plays out
but right now black siren is very much
an evil character the way they cut the
text into the trailer the things you saw
it's all part of the deception they cut
that with Billy's death but because this
is the black siren episode that plays
into the Prometheus arc so in the way
he's set up Oliver to kill Billy he's
also setting up this black siren twist
so somehow he's connected to black siren
either he broke her out of the pipeline
prison or there is some flashpoint stuff
happening here the producers were kind
of vague on how flashpoint would affect
things they'll explain it in the episode
so no worries it's just that there are
very few ways for people to travel
between earths without the help of a
flash like you can only travel through
those little portals if you have
somebody traveling at SuperSpeed so
without some crazy technology there's no
way black siren could come back from
earth-2 so it seems like she's been here
this whole time
but the Prometheus stuff I know people
still want to believe that there's some
other big twist they're obviously gonna
be dealing with Talia al Ghul stuff in
this episode - that goes back to Russia
so I'm wondering how Kovar works in -
Talia al Ghul prometheus stuff because
right now the Talia al Ghul stuff seems
completely separate but they always try
to leave all the storylines together by
the end of the season so it'll all make
sense like you'll understand what Talia
al Ghul is trying to do what she'll be
doing in present day how that ties in
with Prometheus in what Kovar has to do
with it all but along those same lines
they did talk about the flashbacks
because this is the last season of the
flashbacks they have a whole lot of
Russia and Kovar like you see them
getting beat up in this basement down
here there'll be at least one episode
that is almost entirely set in Russia
that's a Kovar episode I mean you have
Dolph Lundgren of course you're gonna
give him his own episode they even tease
that they were going to be making some
sort of Trump kovar joke because
supposedly Trump gets a lot of money
from Russia so there's going to be this
corrupt American businessman million
meeting with Kovar in a big flashback
episode they were like make of that what
you will but they were they were trying
to imply that they're gonna be poking
fun at Trump just a little bit so when
that happens I'll totally pointed out
but typically they don't go after like
real-life politicians because it kind of
dates this show because Obama was only
president for a certain period of time
so if they used him on the show and
somebody was watching this and say like
10 years then it wouldn't really make
sense so that's why Marvel DC typically
used fictional presidents when they do
movies and TV shows but it also tells
you how they might use flashbacks in
future seasons so typically what they've
done in the past and they had this
flashback story line that runs
concurrently with the present-day
storyline so you typically get
flashbacks in almost every single
episode but what it sounds like they're
doing in the future is that they'll do
flashbacks when they're necessary to
provide context so like of a really big
character from Oliver's past showed up
they might do a big flashback to explain
what they did in the past how they met
each other but they're not gonna do it
in every single episode so they're gonna
be a lot pickier about how they use
flashbacks which i think is good because
sometimes the flashback storyline just
drags on but the rush of stuff has been
great so far this season you guys can
let me know though you know big black
siren episode how do you want them to
use the character in Katie Cassidy going
forward there's a number of comic book
ways to explain how they could do a new
black canary but like the other big
thing is there's a new vigilante
character that's gonna be joining the
show for at least a minor arc I don't
know how big a character she's gonna be
but there's a lot of people that are
wondering if she might be the new Black
Canary because the producers are like
it's really hard to do a green arrow
show without a black Canary
so because the show's been picked up for
season six they just make it seem like
there will be some form of Black Canary
in that season whether or not it's Katie
Cassidy or somebody else we have no idea
but also don't forget the Katie Cassidy
will also guest star on legends of
tomorrow now that's probably gonna be
part of Sarah's storyline so it'll
probably be Laurel instead of being
black siren but they haven't fully
explained how that's gonna work the
shows are all coming back next week so
my schedule be a little bit different
because legends of tomorrow is going to
be on Tuesday night
so this is my tentative schedule right
now this might change a little bit but
this is kind of what I'm expecting it to
be between Tuesday and Thursday at least
until some other shows start coming back
later in the year congratulations to the
new flash ring giveaway winner minecraft
full please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video if you guys
didn't know I'm alternating an injustice
giveaway with the flash ring giveaway so
that'll be in like all the DC videos
both arrow and flash and anything else
for the movies too so what's gonna
happen is they just confirmed a Miles
Morales spider-man movie is gonna be
made by Sony like a theatrical big movie
so I'm gonna try to get that video out
by later tonight so we'll see if I can
get three videos out today well you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for the new flash trailer and you can
click here to rewatch the injustice
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight